feel like you give this [ __ ] to like
Gordon Ramsay or something he would just
be like he just loved it he loses [ __ ]
yeah it's sort of love to say that he's
a screamer just like yo I'm rich Brian
I'm Joe G and we're celebrating the ATO
rising head in the clouds album and tour
by cooking for our friends that are in a
summer party house
the thing is though I don't think we
really know how to cook welcome to the
feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion what's up this is Josie he's a
Bryan wish Bryan and you're watching the
best [ __ ] cooking show in the world
in the world so today we're gonna be
making instant noodles for the party and
you're gonna have a lot of instant
noodles on the Latour the 88 degrees and
rising toward
[Applause]
yes that one yes
yeah I'm gonna be having a lot of
noodles on that sore for sure who do you
think's who do you thinks the best ramen
noodle man I think I am personally like
not to [ __ ] on you but like you kind of
did I mean like don't take it that way
I kind of did no I'm kidding gone for
now are we good
like are we gonna have this problem like
for the rest of India I'll put I'll put
up with it for this one but all right
whatever
what's up so you got the end of me and
you have the bun I guess the key to this
is we have to customize our noodle game
as strong as possible into our own style
what are you what are you gonna do with
it I don't know I mean you got that
Indomie I'm getting pretty nervous about
that buy it bro don't worry I got a
special ingredient what the [ __ ] is that
don't worry about it I'm kind of worried
now yeah what is this lamp what is that
it's John dude what is that don't worry
about it what the [ __ ] is that bro it's
Timmy if you like stop saying name this
is freaking me out
wait what do you think it is I have no
idea I little you don't know can I smell
it yeah it's smells like chicken but
it's definitely not chicken dogs chase
them they people do eat them like normal
people pretty normal people
I mean Asians I feel like the only white
people that would eat this [ __ ] are like
people from the woods
yeah not records oh yeah rabbit ah why
do we track Coons do possums I know I
know
possums not horrible
[Music]
all right so you pulled out this [ __ ]
rabbit so you know you think you're
going pretty crazy so I'm gonna let you
go first okay I'm really curious to see
what you're doing with this thing I
think the right way to start is we wanna
we want to put in the meat first what
meat is it this is this is also rabbit
yeah yeah yeah we're making the broth
basically right I think that's oh no
that was not done I think this is the
most [ __ ] up cooking show after it is
we're gonna open late just gonna
casually hold that we go up with the
noodle help me open this Brian yeah
thank you so we want to wait a little
bit start mixing it yeah we were given
some ladles and [ __ ] so if you want to
grab ahold of that you can grab one of
these two perhaps I'm very aware that
we're not supposed to use ladles and
ship for this I just can't find anything
so before anyway you're gonna put it
down what you're gonna put the rabbit
down well I mean like there's nowhere to
put it I'm just take a big space right
there and finish it up just let me hang
on I'll put it down because it's
starting to get disrespectful so okay so
are you [ __ ] with this okay wait I
mean like there's no seasoning it okay
now hold on young man hold on I think we
can still just use one I think it'll
just do the job over all of them yo bah
boom stop zippity-doo-dah bap okay and
if actually if you don't mind mixing it
in okay while I grab some [ __ ] and then
just straight up just like oh yeah put
the egg in there that's probably the
moon do you want to make sure that egg
yolk doesn't break and I'll crush it up
all right crush it up yeah oh [ __ ] this
is a competition I mean I'm fine with
that I know it's lumpy trash so step off
brother I forgot this was a competition
I can't
myself say I just mix the egg up and
then are you like pretty confident in
this one who's gonna be good
that's the thing you're never gonna be
able to tell if I actually know what I'm
doing or not that's the game oh that was
kind of beautiful actually I like didn't
even have to mix it up BAM dude I admit
I was really good I was getting around
the spot yeah yeah
ah [ __ ] it was thrown another egg
what is that someone just said that it
was called Naruto but I'm not we're
eating there really to meet you right
now it's uh it's made out of either fish
skin or fish powder them these are fish
eggs is that Nemo oh and I don't know
I'm not a fan of this personally right
but like this is what people like that's
it that's it what do you call it this I
call it ramen and that now you know
we're gonna see if the student the
student was able to learn from the from
the master who's the master I think I'm
the master in this scenario all right so
you cooked your dish called the ramen
and then I'm gonna say fine
I'm using me going which is kinda like a
fried thing so what I'm gonna do right
now is kind of like put my Ellen law
spin on it okay I don't know what I'm
doing I'm kind of like deciding as I go
what kind of peppers are those they're
Thai Birds okay yeah so I like to just
kind of cut it up like that
watching you cut it up is a lot more
soothing I forgot that you actually cook
there's some onions in here the chopper
just like a little bit more when you're
cutting these up you unlock the flavors
truce comes out yeah I don't know what
I'm talking about I just wanted to sound
professional but I get it yeah so I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna put it in in the
oil so okay oh he already he already
knows what he's doing it's excellent
like I said like looking at that it's
like filming all of it just like smoosh
it to make sure it smells good
and you know I'm gonna put some some
shrimp in you want rabbit for this no
I'm good I think I'm just gonna stay
with shrimp for now okay I'm gonna put
the shrimp in there I just kind of like
want to move it around make it laughs
you got that stir-fry advantage okay so
I'm gonna put the noodles in oh so
Indomie it started from Indonesia but
it's kind of like popular like
everywhere feel like he would give this
[ __ ] to like Gordon Ramsay or something
he would just be like it's love it he
[ __ ] yeah it's what I'd love to say
everybody's a screamer just like [ __ ]
like doing sex is just like these are
the the endo be package that came with
that this is what makes it like endo me
you knows what are the three contents so
this is like it's like some some onion
[ __ ] with like oil and then this is a
sweet soy sauce and this is a chili
sauce and I'm [ __ ] telling you when
you eat this you're gonna [ __ ] your
[ __ ] party nomination my past a lot
of people are coming to this party and I
don't want to disappoint them true so
I'm actually gonna put two eggs on it
yeah because people need protein you put
anything else on somehow opinions that's
it I'm done
[Music]
right so I'm being my noodles and so did
I we've conceived two great bodies of
work and now we're about to try both of
it and decide which one is the official
to animals
try try this part I feel like this is
like the good part right here right here
good good mmm that's very good mmm okay
I taste the peppers it's nice you see
it's a nice little kick
yeah I like it it's really good thank
you
yeah all right I want to try yours now
[Music]
the [ __ ] this is actually like so much
better than mine that's all right
this is so good what you talking
sarcastic no I'm actually v6 what are
you putting this again you put one
seasoning back there right mm-hmm
the rest of it to the aggregate what and
the rat rabbit because we put in earlier
mmm we did Sean post faith in us
you know we delivered I made the noodles
you made yours
which one's gonna be the official one
honestly I'm going for that [ __ ] this
week later if I'm going on surf like two
months I want to have that everything
yeah I feel like this would just spill
all over the place so I'd want to go
with that I mean that's true because
we're going by a bus you're right and
also you can save this stuff in the
fridge that's true this will just like
look like this
all right sorry I we might have to go
with the yeah in the window me damn
alright I had that settled so the enemy
is the official tour noddles august
await nicky higher brothers keep a few
guys didn't come here and you guys
didn't get to decide but this is we're
gonna be getting for the rest and sort
yeah so kidney stones Krispy Kreme
[Music]
I try to take your clothes off one more
time maybe I can let you don't be
calling and impressing me
legatus but you fit better and rickety
we moved under new
really
[Music]